the soar franchise has become a complex
saga comprising many movies
and with the release of spyro from the
book of saw things are about to get more
complicated
we're here to break down the entire
sword timeline one bloody moment at a
time
john kramer's sinister arc begins with
his time as an engineer and building
designer
john works with his friend attorney art
blank on creating low-income housing for
needy families through their urban
renewal group
jill john's wife works as an addiction
recovery clinic
john is concerned over the safety of
jill's workplace especially as his wife
is pregnant with their first child
his fears proved to be well-founded when
a patient named seesaw adams
attempts to rob the facility cecil
shoves a heavy door into jill's stomach
on the way out
causing her to miscarry the couple's
unborn son gideon
cecil had been encouraged to go to the
clinic by amanda young
a fellow addict and patient who was once
arrested by detective
eric matthews john and jill's
relationship falls apart
shortly after this incident a doll john
had created for his unborn son
later inspires jigsaw's ominous vessage
shortly after the decline of his
marriage john is diagnosed with terminal
cancer by dr lawrence gordon of the
angel of mercy hospital
during his treatment john befriends an
orderly named zep hindu
zepp makes it clear that he dislikes dr
gordon his tumor is deemed to be
inoperable because jon was diagnosed too
late
thanks to an x-ray labeling error by
logan nelson john seeks approval for an
alternative treatment option
with insurance executive william easton
a donor to jill's clinic who is
nevertheless type fisted
in a new trial starting he's looking for
new patients
and he seems to think that i'm the
perfect candidate john john is warned he
will lose his coverage with umbrella
health if he pursues experimental
treatment
as a company is quick to cut off clients
in need of care
like cardiac patient harold abbott this
decision comes back to haunt eastern
none of these people know they've made a
grave mistake by simply being in the
vicinity of john kramer
during this dark hour but in time they
definitely find out
after experiencing severe depression
john drives himself off of a cliff
but he survives the crash and gains a
new perspective on life
and an incessant urge to force his
revelation on others
he begins his deadly series of games
with a bit of retribution
concealing himself with a pig mask and
capturing cecil
john places cecil in restraints in his
lab and tells him that he has the choice
to either bleed out from the wounds on
his wrists
or press his face through a series of
blades john insists he'll escape with a
renewed lease on life
however cecil isn't able to complete his
challenge but then his chair breaks
apart and allows him to escape
cecil attacks jon but jon murders him by
throwing him into a cage full of razor
wire
jigsaw reveals logan nelson's for bin
jon's first sidekick
logan fails to wake up during the
initial buckethead trap at tuck's pig
farm
and is badly wounded by the blades but
jon does not believe logan has to die
due to his careless but innocent
x-ray mislabeling jon rescues logan from
the trap
and trains him in his philosophy which
logan finds to be helpful
it is not clear how long logan works
with jon but he helps him prepare some
of his earliest traps
including the reverse bear trap we also
don't know if he had any relationship
with jigsaw's other sidekicks
jigsaw's recruitment spree doesn't stop
with logan mark hoffman is part of the
first metropolitan police department
team
investigating the jigsaw murders
alongside detectives david tapp
steven singh and alison kerry he learns
enough about jigsaw to imitate his
methods
pretending to be jigsaw hoffman gets
vengeance against seth baxter
his sister's murderer via the pendulum
trap jigsaw does not punish hoffman
though he does admonish him for not
giving seth a chance to survive his trap
jon offers to take him under his wing
hoffman also helps jon frame dr gordon
by leaving the doctor's pen light at the
scene of mark's game
after he warns jon that detective tap is
getting close to identifying him
tap narrowly survives a trap blade for
the police but singers killed
thus taps obsession with the case gross
jon also recruits amanda after she
survives her trap
and the three work together to create
several traps including one of the
franchises most unforgettable
after amanda agrees to become jigsaw's
second protege
she helps jon orchestrate the infamous
bathroom trap
she helps kidnap dr gordon who is having
an affair with a student
and adam stanheit who is photographing
gordon for detective tap
amanda sets up the room so that jigsaw
can play his sinister game
gordon wins by soaring off his own foot
and his wife and daughter also escape
zepp with tap's help
gordon drags himself through the holes
of jigsaw's lair and finds a hot steam
pipe to cauterize his leg wound
jigsaw then takes gordon in to help him
recover even devising a prosthetic for
his leg
amanda sneaks back into the bathroom to
affixiate adam who is already bleeding
out
gordon goes on to become jigsaw's secret
helping hand
as revealed in saw the final chapter he
assists with some of the more medically
sensitive tests
including the venus flight trap from saw
two and the mausoleum trap from saw four
he also suggests lindenlin as a test
subject in saw three
i was his patient and he was my
john is finally identified as the jigsaw
killer eric matthews is among the
officers who find his hideout
little does he know jonas kidnapped
matthew's teenage son daniel
and put him into a group trap at the
nerve gas house alongside amanda addison
and several other people have been
arrested by matthews on bogus charges
after almost all of the subjects die
daniel is put into a safe with an oxygen
mask
and hidden in jigsaw's lair detectives
matthews kerry and daniel rigg
arrive with others at jigsaw's lair and
are unaware that the footage of the
group trap they are presented with was
pre-taped
instead of waiting like he is instructed
to do matthews brutalizes john and
forces him to take him to the location
of the trap
while rigg discovers that the source of
the video feed is another empty house
matthews ends up alone at the actual
location and is captured and trapped by
amanda in the bathroom
in saw 3 it is revealed that matthews
breaks his own foot to escape the
shackle
but he is still captured for another
game saw three takes place six months
after matthews has captured
john kramer is near death he gives his
lawyer a box containing instructions for
jill
meanwhile amanda is secretly resorting
to self-mutilation
and creating unsurvivable traps
including one used on kerry
john doesn't want to be replaced by a
murderer and devises one last test for
amanda
john has amanda abducted dr lynn denlon
and puts her into a neck trap
denlen is forced to keep john alive for
the duration of another test
which turns out to involve her husband
jeff lynn and jeff lost her son and have
emotionally neglected their daughter
who was kidnapped before jeff's test
little does amanda know
her survival depends on being able to
let denlon go hoffman slightly tells
amanda to kill denlon
threatening to expose her part in
cecil's attack on jill's clinic
if she refuses amanda refuses to let
denlon go
and shoots her instead jeff enters the
room shortly thereafter
and kills amanda in retaliation for
jeff's final test
jon asks him to show mercy but jeff cuts
his throat with an electric saw
triggering denlon's collar in saw four
it is revealed that hoffman was
pretending to be trapped alongside the
now haggard matthews and art
at the events in john's hospital room
unfolded rig is confronted with several
of art's worst clients
including morgan who just survived the
tests that forced her to kill her
abusive husband
rig is supposed to let his timer run out
but instead rushes into the final room
with hoffman
matthews and art not knowing who's
rushing in matthew shoots rig and
triggers a device that crushes his own
head
rig also shoots art thinking the tape
recorder in his hand is a gun
before rig bleeds out he sees hoffman
reveal himself as jigsaw's apprentice
simultaneously fbi agent peter strom and
his partner lindsay perez
follow rigg's trail perez is injured at
the scene of morgan's test
strand then interrogates jill turk who
leads him to the building john uses for
his
tests strom arrives at john's room just
after jeff kills jon
strom shoots jeff in apparent
self-defense hoffman locks strum in
but he finds an exit however he is then
captured and put into the water cube
trap
strand barely survives by using a pen to
perform a tracheotomy on himself
hoffman then pretends to escape and is
stunned to discover storm also made it
out alive
john's autopsy reveals a tape that
promises hoffman will be tested
hoffman later receives a mysterious note
that warns i know who you are
the notice from dr gordon who'd received
a tape from jill's box in which john
asks him to watch out for jill
strum determines that hoffman was
jigsaw's apprentice after reading up on
the seth baxter case
despite being removed from the case by
his superior dan ericsson
he continues to investigate hoffman jill
complains to eriksen that strahm is
stalking her
meanwhile hoffman works to set up strahm
as a suspect
he stages a group trap involving five
crooked people
connected to a deadly apartment fire
strahm previously investigated
hoffman also used this strahm's cell
phone to lead ericsson to the location
of the group trap upon finding two
victims still alive eriksen puts out an
apb on stram
however hoffman then leads dram to the
nerve gas house and traps him in a room
that crushes him to death
hoffman stages a two-person test so he
can continue framing strom
ericsson grants hoffman unfettered
access to the fbi's investigation
and reveals that perez fakes her death
and is still active on the case
later hoffman carries out jigsaw's wish
for a test on william easton
in which eastern is forced to make life
or death decisions
for a series of his employees finally
the wife and son of the late harold
abbott must decide easton's fate
and they choose to kill him though
jigsaw's work is finally done
hoffman is not in the clear ericsson and
perez soon discover huffman's identity
as soon as the fbi agents realize who
hoffman is however he kills them
the last surprise to come from john's
box for jail is the reverse bear trap
john's box instructs jill to use it on
hoffman however hoffman manages to
survive the device
hoffman manages to divert police
attention by staging the grizzly
horsepower trap as well as the test of
bobby dagon who's made a fortune
pretending to be a jigsaw survivor
after setting a deadly trap for gibson
and other officers
hoffman manages to sneak himself into
the body bag of one of the horsepower
victims to get
access to the police station he kills
anyone and everyone in his way to get to
jill's holding cell
hoffman places jill in the reverse bear
trap which kills her
and prepares to get away however he's
met outside by three men in pig masks
one of them is dr gordon who shackles
hoffman to adam's old spot in the
bathroom
and takes away the saw that would allow
him to save himself
10 years after jon kramer's death a
series of jigsaw-like deaths occur
the bodies are analyzed by logan and his
strangely jigsaw
obsessed assistant eleanor detective
halloran is drawn into the case
but little does he know he's being set
up by logan halloran is a crooked
detective who took a bribe from a man
who murdered logan's wife
the game is a copycat version of the
test logan survived
logan plans puzzle pieces of the new
victims and halloran's frieza to make
him a suspect
logan then forces halloran to admit his
misdeeds by pretending to be trapped in
a two-person test with him
after halloran confesses logan reveals
that he has taped him
people died because of me innocent
people died because of me i did it
he watches as halloran's head is sliced
to pieces in the laser collar trap
game over for now check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single game
you